hey we're here at CES of General Motors
and I just test drove the env it's an
electric vehicle with wireless
communications that enables autonomous
driving it's really cool go forward push
forward
go back pull back you have to pull the
stop that's also stop left is left right
is right it goes about 25 miles an hour
max it's got sensors around the sides to
avoid collisions and also detect other
envies around it so I can automatically
follow them there's like an automatic
driving mode so if you're really too
lazy and too drunk or something could
just hit a button it'll drive for you it
also has the ability to just auto park
which is really convenient they can you
can fit like six of these in one parking
spot I don't think you're gonna see
these on the road anytime soon there's
still concept vehicles just looking
forward at urban settings when the
population is really risen a lot and
lots of congestion but you know five to
ten years I think this could be a really
big deal
you